what up guys welcome to the just pearly
things youtube channel and welcome to
the gray area reactions where we talk
about things that might be in the gray
area a little bit of gray area you know
get people talking and
see what they think you know
before i start do not forget to
subscribe to the channel and bring that
notification bell that way you're going
to be notified of my daily videos while
you're at it go subscribe to sarah's
channel subscribe to my channel please i
need as many you know subscribers as
possible
i'm trying to be like pearl you know he
he's humbling women he talk i'm trying
to nicely right nicely
in the most british way possible
check this out guys studies have shown
that our appearance affects our mental
health and the anti-aging industry has
been capitalizing on this for decades
however many of the serums and the
supplements that are recommended fall
short now i know what you're thinking
why that's because many products on
store shelves don't target the source of
the problem mostly they just hide
wrinkles with cheap ingredients but
lucky for you there is an alternative
the alternative is a solution that
rejuvenates skin from the inside out
this promotes elasticity and
youthfulness which is why i'm such a fan
of multi-collagen multi-collagen helps
combat loose skin and wrinkles this
works quicker and more effectively than
anything else i have tried but listen to
this the real reason that it works is
that you are supercharging the skin's
collagen intake collagen is the protein
our skin needs to stay elastic this
product helps deliver collagen directly
to the skin cells newsflash that's why
it's so effective imagine how good
you'll look this summer by taking it now
if you want to look and feel your best
grab some multi-collagen today get up to
51 off in the next 24 hours by going to
health with pearly or visiting the link
in the description thanks for listening
guys back to the video
[Music]
um so today we are reacting to
child support ruined my life my life oh
wow i lost as a millionaire that's a
deep towel oh wow okay um we'll start it
oh my god i
lost my child support case
this is going to destroy me
i have to pay like five thousand dollars
per month in child support
uh for the next 15 years or something
like that so my retirement is out of the
window now you know i was going to
retire
last week actually but it seems like i'm
back onto youtube now churning out these
videos and i wanted to explain for you
the child support situation that's so
sad damn that's damn that is so cute
he was ready to retire and then child
support was like nope not today my
friend
5 km 5k a month
for 15 years how do these [ __ ] get a
job you see me i got a job
we can work 5k a month like
like why
i don't know i guess i guess we're gonna
find out
how how many kids
i think it's the question for you i
recently lost my case because you too
may find yourself having to pay child
support someday whether intentionally or
even unintentionally as what happens to
many sports superstars and i'll explain
for you the calculations here but before
i begin i want to clarify for you what
happened about three years ago my
japanese wife just one day took our son
three years old at the time and abducted
him taking him off to japan and
wait
she just upped and left stop she just up
and left
and so i'm guessing they're in america
i'm guessing yeah yeah yeah but she's
gone she's taken the child to japan now
that's hor how can she legally be able
to do that we'll see if she can that's
that's crazy
i think you should go to jail as a girl
if you
without any good reason like there's
domestic violence and like things like
that but if you for no good reason just
for your own selfish interest take the
child away from the father i think you
should face jail time do you know what i
had a
guy on my youtube channel who i was
speaking to once and he the the mother
of his child done the same thing like
she upped left took the two children to
ghana
and he he's been trying to access them
and he can't he doesn't even know where
she is
that's crazy like that [ __ ]
that's so because that's so selfish as a
mother you're putting your kid at every
statistical disadvantage why because
your relationship but then what would be
the outcry if a man done that oh my god
people would be pissed
but it's just because i'm so tired of
these girls getting away with [ __ ] just
because they're women
i know you guys are attracted to them
right who's you guys this is what i mean
you guys men men i feel like have more
sympathy for women no they they i think
you guys have a natural like inclination
to protect us on some level
and when you cries
men are like attracted to women right
but i'm straight as an arrow okay
i i cannot as a kid i cannot
i cannot stand when girls do [ __ ] they
just get away with it because they're a
girl
well that's why
as a woman you've got to be the one to
humble these women
nicely yeah nicely in the most british
way possible
i'm getting too british i know i know
about a year ago i lost contact with
them and she has been blocking access
ever since so recently she came after me
hiring an american lawyer and went after
me for child support and she's still out
there in japan now this is not a video
meant to treasure or anything like that
you know like i'm just here to try to
educate you that value is what i'm
trying to provide for you so this really
isn't a personal video and you know some
people by the way are going to say i'm a
deadbeat dad i want to clarify that you
know my son was the most important thing
to me in my life he was the one thing i
could not lose the most important
element in my life that left me very
much traumatized and many fathers who
end up losing their children do end up
unliving so to speak and so really the
fact that i'm even here alive and
somewhat productive is a feat in and of
itself that requires tremendous
emotional willpower a lot of people say
that i refer to my son in the third
person as the child rather than my child
and the reason for that is because it
just makes it too personal and emotional
for me sometimes to talk about this
matter it's an emotional card rather
than me you know what right there's
statistical data to show
that men that lose their children
are
at higher risk of suicide
and what he just said there was very
interesting to me where he said
you know that the fact that he's still
living and breathing is a fever in
himself because he must have had some
sounds like he had some
suicidal thoughts or something i don't
know this is making me so sad
a little bit it's crazy because
like
i don't understand how you could keep a
father from your child if that's the one
person as a mother you were supposed to
love more than anyone in the world it
happens all the time i know but it like
to me i can't even fathom that it
happens all the time like i know a
couple of fathers you know it's happened
to me before do you know what i mean
like i know i know many men this
happened to you so
yeah it's a whole it's an emotional
manipulation tool
it's it's it's not being with somebody
while also being able to control them
how did you get around like your
um
you're like the mother of your child
yeah i'm letting you see your i had to
it was a long process you had to go for
the courts
um you had to go through mediation
like it was a whole process and so
yeah like when he's saying this kind of
stuff it kind of resonates with me and i
can definitely um
relate well and the other thing is it
takes because this is what i've heard
too and i heard this happen during covet
a lot where like the dad's like let's
say one like in january she said you
can't see the kid and then he files like
at the end of january and saying okay
she's not letting me see the kid and
then six months like if the courts get
backed up or something that dad might
not see the kid for months because he
has no penalty yeah
which is crazy because you can't get
that time back no that's the one thing
about when it comes to children is time
you just can't get it back yeah you
really can't and the fact that she's
just up to the left of japan
one of the most selfish things you can
do so selfish
rather than me being inhumane for any
reason but really this is the thing
whatever you value the most your spouse
will learn your weaknesses what you
treasure and take that away from you in
a better divorce when they're angry at
you because they want to retaliate
against you you know if i did not love
my son she probably would see no reason
to block access right there would be no
point in doing that but because i do she
knows she can use that as leverage
against me and to just exact pain upon
me and maybe that's really the
post-breakup game right wow
yeah that's just d that's so crazy
so this is one thing that he loves and
she's just gonna be like okay cool i
know you love this
i'm gonna use it against you
and it's crazy do you think men
see it coming
when this stuff happens because
i think women we see it coming more
because we kind of see girls a little
bit more behind the scenes than you guys
do
so a lot of times like as a girl we'll
be like oh why would he like pick that
girl she's nuts
but it seems like you guys see it but
you see it like later um
we see it and i mean just like being
with somebody is like
you ignore so many signs do you know
what i mean because you're like i'm in
love you know i mean like
and it's like it's true what they say
like it's a cliche but they do say love
is love is blind sometimes yeah do you
know what i mean and i think men
are
men don't want to break the facade of
a woman's like innocence yeah like
they're less likely to now men are like
no these hoes are crazy
but before yeah you know and obviously
when you're married you don't want to
break the facade of like your wife's
innocence yeah so maybe maybe you see it
coming and you ignore it
yeah this is this is crazy to me
game right the other person blames you
for having married them for having
proposed to them because it turned out
that they just wasted their time you
weren't who they thought they would be
you deceived them you didn't play up to
their entire expectations and
imaginations of what a wonderful night
you would be you know it turns out
you're human after all but let me tell
you what happened with child support
court i basically walked into the
courtroom and i just lost i got
slaughtered in there here's what happens
quick pause this video is brought to you
by d5 pro dot dev quest
i know i know we're getting emotional
quick pause guys
i've been getting that back too
quick balls
[Applause]
so to start off i began by hiring an
attorney like any normal person would
and there's all these paperworks you
have to file i ended up blowing through
25 to 30 000 of money within just one
month and it didn't even get me up to
the trial i ended up firing these people
because what happens is once you retain
them you know you have to pay five ten
thousand dollars as soon as you show
them your finances and you know if
you're a higher earner they say you know
what uh we need double the retainer
right away
and they just start building you for
everything if they send out the audacity
of these people
this man's going through like a really
hard time and it's just like yeah give
me your money but
[Applause]
you know what's crazy too
is that
this is a millionaire right but imagine
the average guy you can't fight this
stuff
like i mean i know a guy who
spent like 20k
trying to see his daughter i mean that
was over the course of like a year or so
but yeah and he's the average owner he's
not like a millionaire but it really
took some money out of his pocket now
imagine if there was vice versa a man
was doing that not letting the kids see
their mother
it'd get ripped apart
[Music]
no just imagine just going into the job
no because you've actually done this
stuff yeah like
yeah people because people assume
that the mother is automatically the
better parent yeah than the father it's
just an assumption do you think that's
changing
i i think slowly now because people are
seeing a lot of like
what women can be nowadays do you know
what i mean so i think yeah i think it's
slowly changing well and i think that
the kids grow up and realize the mom was
crazy at some point yeah because like
kids aren't stupid i was watching the
video today uh there's another content
creator and she was saying to like young
children go to your mom and say when i
turn 18
i'm gonna have a serious conversation
with my dad
and i don't want to hear anyone's
input except for my dad's and she said
say that to your mom and see what their
reaction is she said if your mom tries
to stop you from speaking to him
she's the one she's crazy she's the
crazy one he's crazy
if they send an email 10 word email is
40 for that and they just bill you
everywhere if they have a conference 40
for a 10 word email
yeah
the audacity how much is that per word
conversation with a colleague about your
case it's another several hundred
dollars even though you didn't ask them
to have that conversation if you have a
conference call and two of the attorneys
of the firm show up then you get billed
at 2x the rate and the rate is typically
400 500 per hour if it's a good attorney
it could be as high as 800 dollars per
hour and you know you really have to be
careful about these attorneys because
sometimes the other party can come and
ask you to also pay for their attorney
fee so you could be paying 2x3 hours you
know if it's like a 800 attorney for
both sides is as high as hundred dollars
per hour and so the legal system the way
it really works is if you and the other
spouse cannot work together to figure
this out then they're just going to
drain your finances until both of you
can figure something out so in my view
the legal system is not built to try to
help you or to find justice but rather
to just drain your money as fast as
possible until one of you just say you
know what we're just going to give up or
we're going to just settle on something
because this is too much financial pain
for us to take as a family we just can't
afford it somebody has to give in at
that point the other thing to know is
can you imagine like just
using all your money to try and get
something done
and you use all your money yourself and
got it done
do you know it's like is that what did i
use all that money for we still never
came to any kind of conclusion
no i know that's
i just
i just don't understand why these hoes
can't get a job
listen i think i think they become so
unless and a lot of it's men's fault you
know because a lot of men
make them accustomed to a certain
lifestyle
but
stop them from having any other skills
but it's just like okay i grew up in the
one percent half percent but like my
family always taught us to work
like that was just you were either in
sports you were doing school or you were
working like that's that you're not just
staying home and doing nothing for a
summer so i just when i see these girls
that get the lifestyle and then
automatic and then just suddenly lose
their ability to work it just drops
that happens when you like wife like a
stripper or your wife like
i don't know just a barbie yeah who
doesn't have anything but yeah her looks
yeah
i want to know what is
what she looks like
what does your wife look like my friend
i want to know how they met like i have
so many questions notice that mediation
is very difficult you know i made the
back of the envelope calculation of how
much i believed my wife would deserve i
doubled that and i said here take over a
million dollars just take it be happy
let's just move on with our lives very
happy people but the problem is since
she does not know what is the fair
amount any amount that you offer she's
going to say uh maybe i deserve more
than this how do i know this is the
right amount let's get a judge or
attorney to actually stamp none and so
it's very difficult to reach any
agreement so you kind of end up and pick
if you didn't pick the right guy then
learn to pick better like take the l and
move on he doesn't owe you money but he
he i mean offered her a million i know
she got something i know what i'm saying
i think the red amount should be zero
you left you left him and took his son
and you want money
do you know what that's you deserve zero
you deserve zero dollars you can't move
and then ask me for money
you can't sever the tie with money and
then ask for money they are rewarded for
breaking up their home because they can
leave
yeah because they get to leave and then
they get a cash cow
and so it's like
marriage and divorce is becoming a
business now yes it's a business like
that's what i just think the government
shouldn't be in it
why i mean
yeah but then how would you regulate it
the government have to be involved in it
somehow
why
the only like reason the government i
think should be in it is to like maybe
incentivize families so maybe give them
a tax break or something but like i just
genuinely feel like you bear the
consequences of your own
actions if you want to date if you want
to date if you want to date the bad boy
go do it but if you will she dated the
good guy no the good guy if you want to
that's the other side if you want to
date the good guy you're not really
attracted to
that's why she feels like she can treat
him like this because she feels like
she's better than him so if you if you
want to do that that's she has no regard
for his health either physical or mental
because the fact that you can just up
and leave and
right and he's not even thinking about
what he's going to be thinking
yeah and so it's like if you if you want
to do that but like deal with the
consequences
get
women we fought for the right to work
let's use it ladies if you're going to
break up your get to what
if you're going to break up your own
home get a job
i i just don't it's like one thing now
all of a sudden they're like damsels in
distress and you know it's like one
thing if a dude leaves you after 20
years for a younger model that's a whole
nother situation but like
[Music]
she left with a child you left
you laughed
you left they dropped me nuts stamped
this and so it's very difficult to reach
any agreement so you kind of end up
being sucked into the whole legal system
whether you like it or not and all of
your funds goes into the attorneys oh
and also the moment lawyers are involved
they tell you not to talk to each other
anymore because they'll take it from
here and that makes reaching any type of
agreement even more difficult because
nobody's talking anymore and the lawyers
are going to just rack up the fees as
much as they can and continue dragging
out that conversation for as long as
possible in many ways it makes the
situation even worse not to mention i
believe i don't think a single child
abducted to japan which is this black
hole of child abduction like so many
kids get abducted there i don't think a
single child has ever been returned so
any leak over a course it's not even
enforceable so you say any child that's
been abducted to japan has never been
returned
wow
this is this this is a common thing like
women take the kids back to japan he was
saying that he's like a black hole of
abduction wow i've never heard of that
so then
yeah he knows he has no chance of seeing
his son again so question as like
if you uh if she has the son right
and you go in and just take him what can
can she legally do anything take him how
like go in the house and physically take
him yeah
you can get done for like breaking and
entering it's not your property
but i don't think in the uk you can
legally kidnap your own child
okay so
see i'm just i'm very creative so i was
trying to think of a way around it oh
okay like like if he went to japan and
like grabbed and grabbed his
he'd have to have the passport and
everything yeah um
yeah he'd have to
to have like an sas team to like snatch
the child or something do you know what
i mean but he'd have to literally do it
and then have the flag booked and then
go straight to the airport yeah
yeah that's but then you have to think
about the trauma on a child now yeah i
know i'm not i'm not saying this was a
good option i was just trying to think
of a plan c
gosh this is so messed up because the
mother's already
she's already set the boundaries yeah so
it's like she's taking the child so
she's already traumatized the child once
yeah and he could walk and do it again
it's like i don't know if it's a
catch-22 i feel like if they're young
enough they won't know they're like two
yeah yeah yeah they're not gonna know
what's going on yeah but if they're a
little bit older then
yeah you gotta pay a babysitter that's
what actually that is what i would do
let us see i'm very creative
this is what i would do if i was if i
was a dude trying to get a kid
i'm very creative i would get a
babysitter okay and i i'm red pill right
so i would make it her type
whatever her type is the babysitter
right so you get like a nice handsome
babysitter yes
or a feminine woman i don't know whoever
i'm gonna send more than one in you know
what i mean and i'm gonna
i'm gonna give her an event that she
wants to go to right right i don't know
what i don't know how i would do it this
is just how i think okay go on and so
what and then i'd get her to like think
she's invited to some fancy about
something a girl can't turn down it
doesn't have to be real
i mean this is elaborate right now
living in a movie
you know me i would make it happen all
right
i would throw the event myself
she'll turn up if she's the only one
there
but but okay okay
and and what i would do is i would get
the babysitter to give me the kid
that's what i would do yeah or fine it
could be a third party friend that she
doesn't know about i don't know i would
get this is my third party plan if
someone's struggling out there you can
see that i mean
i i wouldn't take pills advice guys do
you know what i mean to do that but
yeah i can't think of another option
what's your other option that was an
elaborate plan look it i think i think
i'm i'm on to something
so here's how child support works it's
actually pretty simple only based on a
mathematical formula how much money do
you make and how much time you spend
with the child that's it and it's an
entirely different case than say divorce
and custody so you know it doesn't
really matter if the other person
abducted the kid to japan for whatever
reason and just blocked all access none
of that really matters whether it's
right or wrong people just come and say
we don't care what happened how much
money do you make and then we're going
to have you pay a percentage of that and
so each state is a little bit different
but if you come into the guideline
calculator there was like a
calculator yeah california child support
services
for california you can actually plug in
some numbers and you'll see that you
know there's really two things that
matter how much money you make we can
put in say 70 000 per month just as an
example and then the percentage of time
that you spend with the child so you
know if you spend zero percent time then
you end up paying more if you spend a
lot of time then you pay less so let's
say you spend zero percent of the time
earn some
get pulled around in child support
because if she holds you the kid from
you and then goes to the child support
court and says he spends zero time with
the kid then she gets then she gets more
money so even even if she was holding
the kid
so basically women are in are monetarily
incentivized to keep the child away from
each other wow
that's crazy
let's say you spend zero percent of the
time earn seventy thousand dollars per
month based on that you would pay fifty
three hundred dollars per month in child
support now if you were to spend fifty
percent of the time with the kid the
calculation would be about four thousand
dollars per month so parents are
actually incentivized to block access to
block as much visitation and take 100
time with the child in order to maximize
the amount of money that they would
receive
so this is an ugly reality really posing
a conflict of interest towards family
values and explains why many people say
children are being used as pawns in
family court to maximize financial value
for one partner or the other but
regardless if you ever find yourself in
a situation like this i would recommend
to stay in the household don't just move
out thinking you're going to get some
peace for everybody and you'll figure it
out later on because the family court is
going to maintain whatever that status
quo is if you want to stay with the kids
and get some custody you need to stay
with them and just go back to that
household even if there's conflict if
the other person gets mad start shouting
telling you to get out of the house just
pull out your phone record it don't
touch them and just continue recording
but don't vacate that house
wow don't vacate the house wow
because the guy thinks he's like doing a
service
to the kid by stopping the conflict
but really
he's like writing doing the writing on
the wall
is that what happened to you
if you saw this video would you do you
think like it would have been easier for
you
um
no i mean do you think she would have
taken the kids anyway yeah
yeah but no it wouldn't have mattered um
yeah it's funny because when you're
dealing with somebody
who
his wife sounds irrational
you know we did it with someone who's
irrational there's no like yeah talking
to them they've decided
it's a good thing you you weren't
actually married to her right you were
engaged
nelly
neddy crossed that finish line oh man oh
you're like thank you listen i'm so
grateful
i'm so grateful then across that finish
line
but then
some guys do cross the finish line and
end up like this guy yeah
wow
all right now here's the thing i wanted
to show you about child support let's
say you make 10 000 per month that's
about 120k income per year which is
maybe typical for silicon valley based
on that you would be paying about
seventeen hundred dollars in child
support with a total of about sixty
eight hundred dollars in take home pay
after the thirty some percent tax rate
but really child support comes out to
about twenty five percent of your net
pay in higher tax brackets maybe it's
anywhere from 15 to 20 percent but in
this range it's 25
now you need to consider also there's
rent right most people actually pay
about 50 of their net income and rent
and this is based on those typical rent
calculators whether you're using the 40x
rule where your annual income needs to
be 40x monthly rent or you're using the
30 rule where you're saying you can put
30 of your annual income into rent but
it all assumes you're putting about 50
of your after tax income into rent child
support will take another 25 and then
the last 25
you get so really it's about half to say
a third of your net disposable income
that's going into child support it's
essentially the maximum amount that they
can take from you for you to still be
half motivated to continue working
so what do you think now do you think
child support should just be scrapped
this is a video this video is red
telling me a little bit because i didn't
i didn't realize exactly the behind the
scenes of how it worked yeah i
understood a little bit
but yeah this is convincing me even
further it should be scrapped
what
i'm so tired of lazy girls like get a
job if you pick to if you pick to do it
get a job
i mean
look
we got a long way to go with this system
if the system's like this right now
there's a long way to go
because
this man's story is a million men story
and it's crazy too because i i've heard
this is something i heard before
so um
if you let's say you on youtube tomorrow
you hit a million right this video goes
viral like the video um
this video this video goes viral you hit
a million you're making let's say 10
million right right then the next you
know people fall off all the time on the
internet yeah yeah people like money
comes and goes
so then let's say the next year you only
make one million you still have to pay
25
and so you may and so you could even get
jailed for not paying that but you don't
have it yeah and that's the number one
way that nba players go broke is they
get choked yes they get the wrong girl
pregnant and so they have because think
about it they're they're signed on these
really big contracts and you know the
mba it comes and goes like that
people people can be cut do you remember
when i was talking about relationship
contracts yeah yeah people thought i was
joking right
see the mad scientist is now not looking
so crazy
i'm not looking so crazy now
not marriages
relationship contracts i'm telling you
you are making
upset you are making a little bit more
sense now the crazy guys looking like
the smart guys the people that don't
know tell them what you're looking for
all right so my so my relationship
contract goes like this there's no more
marriages they're just relationship
contracts reason being is because
marriages are obviously failing divorce
rates are
up to 90 if you're college educated 80
64 in the uk
um so
what you do is you come together with
your significant other
and you say okay cool we're gonna be
together for
one year
however many years you decide okay
you can decide it between the two of you
i'm not okay and then you put all your
stipulations down as to what you need in
that relationship what you want what
your requirements are
and at the end of the year
you decide
to keep it rolling okay or to end the
relationship
so
i'm just trying to understand what would
you put in your contract uh
what would you put would there be how
many times a week we're supposed to have
sex
that's not the contract
if she if she has a kid is that a
stipulation like if you have a kid you
get yeah everything if
you get pregnant within this time then
xyz you guys decide okay
you could also put like if we don't work
out this is what happens exactly with
like if i stay at home for three years
then you pay me out for three eggs it's
all up to you you make the contract
yourself i'm trying to say it makes
sense it's really not a bad idea it's
it's i'm you might have you might be
convincing me of it i don't know
and that's the other thing once you get
a child support order on you it may be
very difficult to retire because people
assume you're going to be bringing in
this income year after year and so if
you suddenly say you want to just retire
and stop working people are going to say
no you got to keep working why is your
income dropping you're capable yeah
that's who we're talking about here's
the key he has to keep up that yeah
threshold well that's why jesse williams
went to court was because he was an
actor and he switched to broadway
oh so it wasn't making as much money on
broadway no
and
she still was mad he's still giving her
most of his broadway check
like i think he's literally giving her
what he makes now which is like
significantly less than what he used to
make this dots but it's like men can't
even follow passion projects and you
don't you can't get that time these
women are trying to break these men yeah
like trying to break these men yeah like
you can't get that time back because
like you're never going to be more
energized than you are today yeah like
you're
getting older
so if a guy wants to like take a risk
and try and go out on a limb and try to
do something different you literally
can't
because he's got chances
yeah and i think you can get it reduced
but you have to go to court and god
knows how long that'll take and god
knows how long if the lawyers will train
you exactly even more yeah
so it's it's a casualty too man
you're capable of working get back to
work you can't just take a break you
have an obligation to continue bringing
in this income whatever it was
established at you can try to lower that
right but people are going to ask why
are you lowering it are you taking a
break you're capable of working but i
think one of the interesting things
about this calculation is it's not based
on what the child needs you know some
celebrities are paying hundreds of
thousands of dollars per month 115k
for alex rodriguez
man what does a child do with all that
money he would have he would have given
his child a trust fund or something why
does he need to give that money each
month to get a job get a job i wonder
how much he's he's worth
i don't know
that's crazy
child support what child actually needs
that much money for support is simply
based on a percentage of your earning
income and so this can even be enough
sufficient to retire on for some people
right like if i'm paying five thousand
dollars per month that's actually not
taxed for the other person that's
equivalent to about a hundred k annual
income that's what a good job is going
to pay you simply for child support and
so this is why a lot of wow and it's not
taxed i didn't even think about that
because he's the one paying the taxes
yeah
so it's like the just
wow
just this is
the system is flawed no wonder these
girls are stealing condoms
but drake right yeah yeah
get the right guy get pregnant by the
right guy
and
the money will start rolling in you face
no consequences at all
wow
the celebrity sports stars football
players are coached not to just get with
random people because they could be
taken in for a ride on child support
which will last typically until the
child reaches age 18 or so and i also
wanted to note at least for my situation
it was not sufficient for me to say i
have a separate business i have a
separate llc company for my youtube
stuff for my other businesses people
just imputed all of that income on me
they didn't separate it and they even
took a look at some of my business
expenses like travel expenses and they
said you know what this is all going to
be uh not considered and they're going
to consider that part of income as well
they wouldn't accept that as business
expenses they looked at rent that my
business would be paying to my parents
right like you know i rent space for my
parents they said you know what we don't
believe it you're just living with your
parents so even that was not considered
a legitimate business expense so they
just imputed a lot of income on me so
the courts can be worthless maybe in my
situation people just said hey that's a
youtube channel that's not a real
business youtube isn't a real business
therefore we're not going to allow any
of those business separations or
protections maybe i didn't hire a good
enough lawyer but in either case you
know the money has never been important
for me i just wanted to get to a point
where my ex-wife would be somewhat
appeased and just get to some settlement
any agreement is fine by me i'm
perfectly happy having a cup of coffee
at home playing video games so it
wouldn't change my life one way or
another and for those people who are
saying i should get into this huge
illegal court battle and fight for my
rights you know i just don't believe
that a legal victory is a personal
victory right like legally you can win
whatever you want but if it leaves
everybody just bitter and angry i would
not consider that a victory necessarily
and last of all what is just money after
all and you know what they say if your
only problem is money then you don't
have a problem but that'll do for me
hope you enjoyed the episode let me know
your thoughts in the comments below see
you there if you liked it
wow wow i want does he ever get to see
his kid
that's that's what i got from him he was
saying if he was to win in the courts
for child support wouldn't necessarily
mean that he sees his child yeah so he's
like okay cool i won my court case but i
still don't get to see my
that's sad man
i'm just i don't i just want to know if
he he forgot to see his kid like if she
had no no i think he's got more videos
so i'm guessing you might give us like
an update but that's crazy this red told
me a little bit and i definitely have a
better understanding of like how that
works is it i don't know if it's similar
in the uk or not but i would imagine in
what way what do you mean like the way
the court works with this yeah it's
similar
it's similar i mean child
child support or csa um
sometimes it can work
in a woman's not in a woman's favor as a
matter of fact because
she may think
her man or her child's father is making
more than what he actually is
and if she says because he might he may
be giving her a certain amount even
every month
and she's like i want more
he's like well this how much i'm giving
you and then i know i've known people
jumping out all right i'll take it to
child support
sorry and they get less wow
this is
this is i usually run pill people but
this red killed me on camera i read
pills
okay guys um let me know in the comments
what you'd like to see us react to next
week don't forget to subscribe to the
channel like the video on your way out
and we will talk to you next time bye